I would like to see the president the
president nominee understand that we are
part of a bigger world and we have a
responsibility as part of that right now
our foreign aid budget is point 0 1
percent of our gross national product we
are one of the lowest actually we are
the lowest in the entire developed world
what if we would raise that just to give
you an idea in the area that I focus on
which is education for all we in the
past two years we've given 465 million
dollars we're currently spending 60
trillion dollars every year in Iraq so
if you do the math that means two days
worth in Iraq basically is the
equivalent of what we're spending on
children per year what if we doubled
that how would that be amazing to change
the world and so for me the bigger issue
is the United States needs to reengage
in the world take up its
responsibilities most of these funds
that i'm talking about have been we
pledged billions but we're giving is
millions
you